Peter when we first met you I believe it
was 2014 in the summertime so it's
almost been four years now
exactly and we heard from you and this
this interview is done incredibly well
as all yours have but this one I'd love
to play it for you if you don't mind
sure okay great great I know this feels
like a Senate hearing but it's not I
just I didn't do anything criminal I
remember that about my lawyer
good okay no this is about we'll keep it
on screenwriting here and we have a
great clip to play so here we go whoops
and though I'm no good at it the reason
that I'm a teacher and a consultant and
a story doctor is that I my big secret
is I don't enjoy writing screenplays I
tried for a while to do it but it's not
my thing I coach repayed I'd be in the
chips because I'm a poet that's what I
love to write and I also like to write
novels but years ago the reason I became
what I am is I failed to complete a
screenplay it got huge interested and I
realized at the end of it says I don't
like this form it's just not for me I
love analyzing it I love understanding
how it works I love helping other people
do it but I don't enjoy sitting down
every day and writing in the screenplay
form it's not my thing okay yeah great
so that was four years ago
and what I found from from an email from
you is that you've actually completed a
historical TV series yeah and I still
hate writing okay so I'm always gonna
hate it okay I was just telling Susie
yesterday god I hate this but I'll tell
you yes I've had some success and what's
great about that is is that it's here
here's the really great thing because
when you're a teacher you don't really
know for sure my stuff actually helps it
actually turns out to work that stuff
I've been teaching actually has helped
me which is a huge relief because when
you're a teacher you're often up there
and it's easy to pontificate and say oh
do this and this form try this tool and
but most some of my too
were terrible but a lot of them actually
worked but I still hate writing and I I
that's always probably going to be the
case and I think maybe there are some
writers who don't hate writing who they
just love it and they get 10 in the
morning and I can't wait to get to the
desk but I'm always gonna love it
but it is I guess I'm good enough at it
now to get paid and so I'll do it it's
it's actually fun to get paid yeah and
it's fun to know that your stuffs
actually gonna be out there but yeah I
mean and I'll tell you something else I
I've been consulting and even ghost
writing and and and story doctoring and
teaching for 20 years and I quit writing
I quit the whole idea that I was gonna
write like at least 6 times I was like
screw this and I met it this is terrible
it's awful I'm never gonna succeed and I
stopped I stopped for several years and
I did that several times because the
process of writing is so excruciating I
think for me and for other people you
know I have to say my my lovely bride
Suzie is a very successful writer in
South Africa and we can cut this if she
doesn't like tell this story she's very
successful in South Africa as a writer
she has a a column and she's created her
own voice something she came here and
she started studying television and oh
god she's frowning at me I probably
shouldn't say this anyway she said my
god this is hard and and and and it is
hard so film and television structure is
difficult it's a difficult form to
master it has so many different
components I think if you're a writer if
you're a novelist it's difficult to all
writing is hard but television and film
are excruciatingly ly complex there are
so many moving parts to doing that
that I think it may be one of the harder
writing forms and it was certainly the
case for me that that's the case so yes
I I stand by the fact that I hate
writing so what changed I'm sorry to
interrupt but what what changed I guess
I got that I guess I got people that
wanted to pay me to co-write with them
as opposed to just story doctor so I
would and because of that and also I
found the right partner and here this is
critical especially when you're writing
in television and film I know people
that do it alone and they're great I
don't know how that's even possible I
highly recommend that you get a partner
a writing partner I've had a couple in
the last year that have been marvelous
for me and when you find the right
partner it's almost like you've gone
from a singles bar to a couple it's like
oh yeah I love you and yes you're here
you can help it and I'm not alone oh
yeah and that's really what it feels
like it's like and also they'll admire
you and they tell your great and that's
something you need someone to tell you
you're great when you're a writer
because you feel like crap all the time
and you're also getting producers and
managers and agents whose main job is to
tell you your crap that's what they do
this is crap this is pretty much you
just put that on
autoplay when your oh I'm my managers
calling what are they gonna say they're
gonna say this is crap yeah and that's
what they do it this is crap how dare
you I just talked to someone about this
story well they say it's crap Peter it's
absolute crap and I have to say again
that is also what you got to get used to
in the commercial field which is that
and I think William Goldman said this a
long time ago and I didn't realize so
true was he said everything everything
is a piece of he says when they
refer to your script they just may have
bought it for a million dollars like a
hey I just read your piece of you
know you're we're filming your piece of
next week right it's a piece of
so anybody who feels like well I'm
gonna be validated
I need to be affirmed and you should not
go into the hollywood writing business
because whatever the culture is that
originated in hollywood and i think it
was a bad deal for writers i think i'm
back in the 30s we gave up our
birthright for a mess of pottage and
when we said hey we don't need our name
on the it's not our movie we're just the
write whatever happened back then
there's a toxic relationship that was
commemorated back then between the
writer and the producer and the
relationship is the producers in charge
the writers sort of servile and and
they're gonna get the abuse and whenever
there's a problem it's usually a problem
for the writer it's the Perdue it's not
the producers problem it's the writers
problem you just didn't write it well
enough right so you are gonna get a lot
of criticism and abuse even when they
say they like your thing even when they
buy your thing you're still gonna be
well it's a piece of it's it's and
that's just sort of seems to be at least
in my experience what it's like so you
need a writing partner to grab your hand
left okay darling yes we're great aren't
we yes we are it doesn't matter what
they say yes we're great and that's what
writing partners can do for you I highly
recommend you do not do this alone
you